nikki Haley quits the UN makes a
catastrophic prediction regarding global
warming and President Trump goes after
Taylor Swift much to my producers great
dismay I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show well after the laughter and
revelry of all the Brett Kavanaugh
confirmation it turns out that today is
indeed a sad day because two icons two
icons were lost to us nikki Haley for me
you an ambassador nikki Haley for me she
resigned today we'll talk about that in
just a second and Taylor Swift came in
for some harsh critiques from President
Trump much to my producer Sonya's dismay
so we will get to all of that as well
but first let's talk about that thing
that you are wearing on your wrist is it
nice that watch
I don't think so is it as nice as this
watch no it is not as nice as this watch
how do I know because you don't have a
movement watch do you do you well you
certainly should movement has come
pretty far from being crowdfunded kids
working out of a living room in the past
year they've not only introduced a ton
of new watch collections for men and
women they've also expanded sunglasses
and fashion-forward bracelets for her I
have a movement watch my wife has a
movement watch I should have two of them
my parents both have movement watches
they make a great gift they are really
nice looking watches for not a
particularly luxurious price movement
watches are all about looking good and
keeping it simple they don't tell you
how many steps you're taking or how many
calories you burn all they do is tell
you the time which is what I watch is
supposed to do movement watch a start at
just $95 at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks movement
figured out that by selling online they
could cut out the middleman and save on
cost and you reap the benefit get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
shapiro that's MVM t comm slash shapiro
classic designed quality construction
style minimalism see why the movement
keeps growing MVM t-dot-com
slash up here to check it out so today
is indeed a sad day ambassador nikki
Haley United Nations ambassador nikki
Haley my spirit animal she decided that
she was going to resign apparently a few
days ago and that was just announced
today all I can say is I'm stuck in a
glass cage of emotion a glass cage of
emotion I'm so sad right now
I'm the sadness overwhelms me at times
if I have to take a break to go
cry in the corner and just rock myself
and eat ice cream that might be
happening a little bit later in the show
we'll try to avoid it as best we can
nikki Haley made that announcement in
the White House with President Trump
today it was a shock announcement here's
what she had to say um it has been an
honour of a lifetime I know I said I am
such a lucky girl to have been able to
leave the state that raised me and to
serve a country I love so very much has
really been a blessing and I want to
thank you for that
now nikki Haley was indeed a badass in
her job as the UN Ambassador she
basically spent every day going and
yelling at despots which was inches
great at it I mean she would go in and
she would talk about how the United
States was exceptional and America was
unique place and our allies like Israel
were worth supporting and how the UN was
basically the most Eisley of the
international institutional sort of lay
out and she was exactly correct about
all of those things I will miss nikki
Haley greatly she explains some of the
things that she got done as UN
Ambassador most excited to look at the
two years look at what has happened in
two years with the United States on
foreign policy now the United States is
respected countries may not like what we
do but they respect what we do they know
that if we say we're going to do
something we follow it through and the
president proved that whether it was
with the chemical weapons in Syria
whether it's with NATO saying that other
countries have to pay their share I mean
whether it's the trade deals which have
been amazing
they get that the president means
business okay so there are but a bunch
of rumors about what's going to happen
next
people suggesting that nikki Haley is
going to take Senator Lindsey Graham
spot Lindsey Graham is going to become
the the UN Ambassador that's not going
to happen I'm just gonna say that right
here right now Lindsey Graham has no
interest in giving up a Senate seat to
go be UN Ambassador it would be a great
solution it would be really
Machiavellian to move her into the
Senate where she could just do battle
with Kamala Harris on a daily basis it
would be spectacular
I would enjoy watching it and Lindsey
Graham would actually make a terrific UN
ambassador because it would be full time
Lindsey Graham 2.0 that's all that he
would do all day long would be Lindsey
Graham 2.0 and just yell at people which
would be amazing but unfortunately I
don't think that's going to happen there
are some rumors that maybe it'll be Dena
Powell who is a former member of the
administration or maybe it'll be brick
Rennell who
would be terrific he's our current
ambassador to Germany I really doubt
that they're gonna call him back from
Germany to make him you an ambassador
there are a few other possibilities
nikki Haley is is not going to stay with
the administration she's out she is not
going back to the Senate my guess is
that she is gonna go back into politics
maybe a couple of years from now but I
get the sense from her from from folks
who know her that she actually does just
want to take some time out that she's
sort of been burned out on this job and
I hear her I mean that's that's a pretty
brutal job I met with ambassador Haley
just a few months back and it's not the
easiest job in the world going in there
every day number one having to watch
what the administration is saying and
doing and number two having to go in
with some of the worst people on earth
and tried to negotiate with them on a
regular basis so good for Nikki Haley
and she certainly has all sorts of
gratitude from folks like me for
everything that she did I'm very sad
indeed to see her go meanwhile the
United Nations put out a report and this
is getting all sorts of press on the
left and so I think it's worth going
through in detail so the UN is is not a
good institution it is a an institution
that is replete with the interests of a
lot of very very bad nations who have
interests that are not quite American
interests but one area where the UN
actually has done some research one area
where science is supposed to take the
leading role is with the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change there's a big report out today it
came out on Monday actually and it is a
report all about the supposed at higher
risk from climate change even with a
lower level of climate change so we were
told for many years that over the course
of the next century we were gonna get to
three to four degrees Celsius in across
the planet doesn't the average climate
change and then it turns out that this
new report basically says that we are
warming less fast than the than the UN
thought we were so the UN keeps giving
these 10 year window saying in 10 years
we're really gonna blown it in five
years we're gonna blown it in three
years we're gonna have blown it well now
the new report this should be the
headline today it's not the headline the
new report basically suggests sort of
the opposite that this is in Chapter two
of this new report and the key quote
says quote there is high agreement
across various lines of evidence
assessed in the report that there are
in carbon budget from 1.5 degrees
Celsius or 2 degrees Celsius would be
larger than the estimates at the time of
the r5 the a r5 is the last big study
they did that was back in I believe
2013-2014 what that means you know in in
non-science peak is that it turns out
that our carbon emissions have been
lower than they thought they were when
they first made their estimate which
means that the climate is warming it's
slightly a lower rate than they thought
it would be at this point so the
estimated date for hitting 1.5 degrees
Celsius of global warming is actually
it's been pushed out further now they
were saying that we were gonna hit that
in 3 4 years
now they're saying we're gonna hit that
in 10 years they keep pushing that down
the line the reason that this creates
some skepticism among folks is not
because people don't necessarily believe
in climate change at all is that the
climate is not changing it does raise
questions as to the sensitivity of the
climate to human produced carbon
emissions human-produced greenhouse
gases skepticism I think is warranted
with regard to some of the more
outrageous claims that are being made by
UN members and radical leftists who do
indeed many of them have an alternative
agenda and I'm not just saying they have
an alternative agenda they're basically
saying so there's gonna be Eric Holt's
house who is a meteorologist and a
visiting scholar at at um and IO n I'm
not sure what the University of
Minnesota I suppose and he he actually
calls for an end to capitalism in order
to fight climate change now there are a
lot of folks on the right who have been
suggesting for a long time that was
actually the agenda here that all of the
worry the extreme worry about climate
change was really designed to hamper
America's economy in the world and the
evidence for this was actually presents
right there was evidence that for
example the Paris Accords which were
demands on the United States that we
were supposed to radically shift how we
did business while other countries made
empty promises about how they did
business right China suggested for
example that they were committed to
reducing greenhouse gases after peaking
in 2030 well American Studies already
showed that China was planning on
peaking its greenhouse gases in 2030s
they promised to do something they're
already going to do India promised that
they were going to gradually lower
greenhouse gas emissions at some point
in the future so that promise didn't
mean anything and so a lot of folks in
the United States were saying well why
are we committing ourselves to attempts
and targets when the world
greatest emitters and polluters are not
actually tying themselves to anything of
substance here
well Eric holthouse he says this if
you're wondering what you can do about
climate change the world's top
scientists just gave rigorous backing to
systemically dismantle capitalism as a
key requirement to maintaining
civilization and a habitable planet I
mean if you're looking for something to
do so the idea is that we have to get
rid of capitalism completely where is he
getting this from in the report well
there's a section in chapter 4 of this
UN report that says increasing evidence
suggests that a climate sensitive
realignment of savings and expenditure
toward low emission climate resilient
infrastructure and services requires an
evolution of global and national
financial systems estimates suggest that
in addition to climate friendly
allocation of public investments that'd
be like building levees and ensuring
that there is infrastructure a potential
redirection of 5 to 10 percent of annual
capital revenues is necessary so
basically the entire profit margin
should be redirected as the UN suggests
that it should be redirected now there
are several problems with this report
the first problem is the way that it's
actually reported by the mainstream
media so the way that the New York Times
reports this is that it's a landmark
report from the UN scientific panel on
climate change painting a far more dire
picture of the immediate consequences of
climate change than previously thought
except that's not really true not much
change between the 2013 report and this
particular report the AR 5 in this
report not much changed at all in fact
the only thing that really changed is
that they said that their forecasts for
doom it has actually been pushed out a
few more years but the way the New York
Times covers this is that everyone is
going to die at 1.5 degrees Celsius
change by 2040 as opposed to 2 degrees
Celsius change by 2040 the report issued
on Monday by the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change says that a world it
describes a world of worsening food
shortages and wildfires a mass die-off
of coral reefs as soon as 2040 a period
well within the lifetime of much of the
global population when the New York
Times says that what they want you to
picture is the day after tomorrow that
movie with Dennis Quaid we're suddenly a
giant tsunami just washes through New
York City and sets the whole place under
ice for a thousand years and global
warming is responsible for the rise in
the sea levels and everyone dies and
it's catastrophic it's deep impact
except with climate
the problem is that that's not really
true all of this climate change is going
to happen over the course of the next
century human beings are pretty good and
adaptable when it comes to adapting over
time to threats that present themselves
over time climate has been changing
across the world for the last century
and a half we listen to 1880 1870 and
human beings have been migrating and
moving and developing new technologies
to deal with all of that and the same
will hold true in the future as well now
to talk a little bit more about the UN
report in just a second but first let's
talk about how you can save some money
on your postage okay so every time you
go to the post office it cost you money
to actually get in the car and drive to
the post office it cost you time because
you have to get in the car and go to the
post office no more now you can get all
the great services of the post office
from stamps com you can access all of
their amazing services right from your
desk 24/7 when it is convenient for you
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package using your own
computer and printer the mail carrier
picks it up just click print mail you're
done could not be easier we use stamps
Commons daily wire offices save
ourselves time save ourselves money and
again we use it because it is so super
efficient and right now there's a
special offer when you use promo code
Shapiro's you get up to 55 bucks of free
postage plus a digital scale and a four
week trial again that stamps calm before
you do anything else there's a radio
microphone at the top of the page type
in Shapiro and you save all of that
money 55 bucks free postage digital
scale four week trial go to stamps calm
promo code Shapiro again all those great
services of the post office without
actually having to travel down to the
post office pretty spectacular deal when
you use promo code Shapiro stamps comm
and for promo code Shapiro so according
to Bill hare who's author of previous
IPCC reports and a physicist with
climate analytics and nonprofit
organization they're a left-leaning one
we are not aware of this just a few
years ago it's quite a shock and quite
concerning so this is the first report
commissioned by world leaders under the
Paris agreement which again is that 2015
pact that people supposedly signed but
really made no real commitment to keep
and Trump said this is a waste of time
and pulled us out of it so the authors
found found that if greenhouse gas
emissions continue at the current rate
the atmosphere will warm up by as much
as two point seven degrees Fahrenheit
one point five degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial levels by 2040 inundating
coastlines and intensifying droughts and
poverty
there are significant problems I should
mention in climate change modeling none
of the models that been put forth so far
actually reflect the level of climate
change that's been occurring virtually
all of them overshoot the mark and
that's because climate is actually very
difficult to predict there are a lot of
factors that are involved in climate now
how much of climate change is caused by
human activity certainly some the IPCC
says 80% folks like Roy Spencer who I'm
sure you've heard on other talk radio
shows heard in my Rush Limbaugh Roy
Spencer he says that he thinks it's
about 50% but certainly our contribution
to greenhouse gas emissions leads to
climate change the question is really
not whether that's happening it's to
what extent and also what the economic
damage is from such climate change what
the human damages from such climate
change so the New York Times is playing
this up as much as humanly possible
avoiding the most serious damages
requires transforming the world economy
within just a few years say the authors
who estimate that the damage would come
at a cost of 54 trillion dollars but
while they conclude that it is
technically possible to achieve the
rapid changes required to avoid 2.7
degrees of warming they conclude it may
be politically unlikely for example the
report says that heavy taxes or prices
on carbon dioxide emissions perhaps as
high as 27 thousand dollars per ton by
2100 would be required that's a $40 per
gallon tax on carbon that's what you're
talking about
every time you go to the pump and you
buy 10 gallons of gas you'd now be
paying $400 in tax in order to meet that
27,000 dollars per ton number the Obama
administration had suggested $50 per ton
and that was considered high at the time
hey all of this is to say that these
estimates are wildly overstated in terms
of the amount of damage that they are
likely to do the reason that I say that
is because the report itself the way
that these these things get reported in
the media is that there is virtual
certainty in the scientific community
that this stuff is going to happen the
problem is that virtual scientific
consensus doesn't actually exist on a
lot of key issues so for example as I
pointed out this morning there are
significant questions in the report
about the level of confidence in
specific in specific predictions so in
just second I'm going to talk about
those specific predictions
hey so here's here's what you need to
know about the IPCC so the IPCC makes
two types of predictions in this report
the first type of prediction is that two
degrees of global warming will be worse
than 1.5 degrees of global warming
Celsius okay and they say that with high
confidence meaning by their metric 8 in
10 confidence 80% confidence okay well
that sounds fair right I mean seems like
more global warming would be worse than
less global warming that seems like the
assumption that we're going on then they
get to the actual specific predictions
and with those virtually every specific
prediction they make about the amount of
damage that's going to be done to the
world climate based on 1.5 degrees
Celsius of change virtually all of their
predictions are couched in terms of
medium confidence medium confidence
according to the IPCC at least according
to a 2007 report where they defined the
terms it's the only place I could see
them in defining the terms medium
confidence means a 50/50 shot
so basically flip a coin as to whether
they are right or wrong on this and then
you're going to determine whether we
ought to destroy capitalism on the basis
of this so for example in the in the
first chapter well in the summary rather
in the summary of findings for the IPCC
report it says of the 105 thousand
species studied 6 percent of insects 8
percent of plants 4 percent of
vertebrates are projected to lose over
half their climatically determine
geographic range for global warming of
1.5 degrees Celsius
compared with 18 percent of insects 16
percent of plants and 8 percent of
vertebrates for global warming of 2
degrees Celsius so basically everything
is going to double everything is going
to double or and for insects it's gonna
triple everything bad is gonna double
and then for insects triple with 2
degrees Celsius of change versus 1.5
degrees Celsius of change but that is
expressed at medium confidence okay so
there's a 50/50 shot there right are you
willing to bet the future of the world
economy and leave billions of people in
poverty in developing nations on a 50/50
bet that they are right about the spread
of insect restricted areas and in really
I is that is that a bet that you're
willing to make because now you're
taking a virtual certainty that hundreds
of millions of people will live in
poverty and increased conditions of
poverty and you're betting that against
the 50/50 possibility that some
we'll have less space to live or that
16% of plants will lose half their
climatically determined geographic range
now that's a serious consideration but I
think that there's also the possibility
that number one the scientists are wrong
and number two there's the possibility
the technology tends to actually
manifest itself in different ways that
when you see serious economic serious
environmental problems technology is a
good way of mitigating against that in
fact there's a good case we made the
global warming because it's a greenhouse
effect it has acted kind of like a
greenhouse what you've seen is an
increased greening in certain parts of
the globe
specifically because of global warming
and that's sort of a repeated thing in
this IPCC report the more specific they
get the lower their confidence levels so
for example they say about approximately
four percent of the global terrestrial
land area is projected to undergo a
transformation of ecosystems from one
type to another at one degree Celsius of
global warming compared to 13% at two
degrees Celsius of global warming so if
it's 2 degrees Celsius global warming
13% of the entire global terrestrial
land area is going to be transformed in
terms of ecosystem but again they say
that with medium confidence so they say
with full confidence is that 2 degrees
is worse than 1.5 degrees what they say
with medium conference confidence
meaning half-half is that this change
will be really really dramatic right
that that's basically the case that they
are making now when I say all this folks
on the left immediately say well you're
a climate change denier again I'm not
denying climate change is taking place
I'm asking what the actual impact of
climate change will be and to what
measures will be necessary in order to
curb said climate change so I want to
take another story that's in the news
today because it's sort of astonishing
it's sort of astonishing yesterday
Haggai won the Nobel Prize in Economics
his name is William Nordhaus he works
over at Yale and the left champion this
guy William Nordhaus why his William
Nordhaus has for years been modeling
what sort of economic systems would be
best in terms of curbing global warming
and this has been his actual life work
so the left said oh look at that that's
a slap against Trump it's a slap against
the right finally we are rewarding
someone in economics who takes global
warming seriously but there is a serious
problem with this particular take on
William Nordhaus and Romer the guy who
he won a Nobel Prize
economics with it turns out the Dera
arguments actually undercut some of the
arguments being made by the same folks
who are promoting them and promoting
this IPCC report I'll explain in just a
second first let's talk about improving
the quality of your business you want to
get better employees you wanna get rid
of the bad ones and you want to replace
them with good ones
I know you do Colt I'm looking at you
nodding right there well if you do don't
don't be so sure Club if you do check
out Dale zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire zip recruiter is the best site for
job finding ok unlike other job sites if
recruit does not wait for candidates to
find you instead zip recruiter finds
them for you they have powerful matching
technology scanning thousands of resumes
identifying people with the right skills
education experience for your job and
actively inviting them to apply so you
get qualified candidates fast you don't
have to sort through the wrong resumes
you don't have to wait for the right
candidates to apply it's no wonder that
zip recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the United States that
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews and
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash at
daily wired go check it out for free zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire that's why we use it at the daily
wire offices ourselves zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire and try it out for
free ok so as I say a lot of folks on
the Left very excited about William
Nordhaus actually winning a Nobel Prize
in Economics for his work on the
economics of climate change there's only
one problem with this Nordhaus actually
argues that we should only intervene
economically we should only shift our
economy when the cost of not intervening
outweigh the cost of intervening which
makes a lot of sense right so if you are
not going to intervene and the costs of
climate change are really high then you
should intervene right this is how you
make all your decisions in life I can
make every decision in life the cost of
me acting is it better or worse than the
cost of me not acting so what Nordhaus
basically says is we have to determine
whether the cost of action is more
expensive than the cost of inaction what
point does that become a reality at what
point do we actually have to act well
according to mr. Nordhaus the actual
number is the optimal temperature
increase where we have to act is when
there is a climate change of 4.1 degrees
which is about two point
three degrees Celsius okay so higher
than anything the IPCC is talking about
in fact his model is called dice and
there is a 2013 model version that he
posted in an Excel table the key data
here is that he estimated a cost in the
year 2100 of 4% of global GDP which is
the equivalent of reducing annual growth
over the century from about 2.2 7
percent to 2.2 2% or postponing the
prosperity of 2100 until 2103 so if the
worst-case scenario is hit he is talking
about a cost in the year 2100 of 4
percent of GDP which is not all that
high we can cope with it it's something
that we can deal with in August he
actually published an updated discussion
of this model I talked to the Oren cast
this morning who's an expert on this
stuff over at Manhattan Institute's his
wonderful work like me yeah I think he's
a what you'd call lukewarm err meaning
that he believes that global warming is
happening but he's skeptical with a lot
of the answers that are being given for
how to curb it according to Oren
Nordhaus published a discussion of his
latest model in the American economic
journal in which he argued that holding
warming below 2.5 degrees Celsius is
implausible and not cost-effective in
other words we've already hit 1.5
degrees Celsius we probably already had
2 degrees Celsius there's nothing we can
do there
he says the optimal trajectory would be
mitigation that reduces warming from 4.2
degrees celsius 23.5 degrees celsius by
2100 here's what he says he says the
International target for climate change
with a limit of 2 degrees Celsius
appears to be infeasible with reasonably
accessible technologies even with very
ambitious abatement strategies so in
other words the person that the left is
now celebrating for winning the Nobel
Prize in Economics because it's a slap
at Trump doesn't agree with them and
doesn't agree with the IPCC on the sort
of action that is necessary in order to
avoid catastrophe so that's pretty it's
pretty important thing to know you would
think but the media is not covering any
of that stuff instead they're just going
with the fully alarmist idea that we are
on the brink of disaster and we're all
going to die the IPCC report by the way
makes a bunch of political statements
many of them are uncalled for including
they go after nuclear energy so if you
actually did want to curb carbon
emissions if you actually did want to
prevent global warming by curbing
greenhouse gases presumably
you'd be in favor of nuclear power but
the IPCC authors because they are
politically of the left oppose nuclear
energy here's what they say they say
nuclear energy can increase the risks of
proliferation have negative
environmental effects eg for water use
and have mixed effects for human health
when replacing fossil fuels yeah that's
just not true
studies show that the nuclear energy
industry is the safest industry in
making electricity climate scientists
found that nuclear energy has saved 1.8
million lives by preventing premature
deaths from air pollution is according
to Forbes calm where nuclear was 19
percent of US electricity last year
solar and wind still constitutes just
one point three and six point three
percent of electricity but the IPCC is
saying forget nuclear forget coal forget
gas instead we need to bank on solar and
wind yeah good luck with all of that
good luck with all of that all of this
seems frankly like an attempt to avoid
the to avoid the reality which is that
we have to make economic decisions based
on possibilities and probabilities that
you don't get to destroy capitalism
wholesale just because you don't like
capitalism and when you hear people
saying wild things about how the cities
are gonna be under water and millions of
people are going to die and all the rest
just remember that there is an agenda
backing some of these folks and that the
alarmist predictions of folks like Al
Gore have not in fact come true doesn't
mean we shouldn't take global warming
seriously we should but that's why we
should use money for abatement that's
why we should be looking at building
levees it's why we should be looking at
creating barriers to tsunamis and
figuring out exactly how to move people
inland it means that there are lots of
ways over the course of the coming
century for us to deal with some of the
increased problems of climate but
exaggerating the problems of climate
ain't going to do it and then suggesting
that we overthrow capitalism to do it is
not exactly a smart solution nonetheless
radicalism rules the day and it's it's
driven by a sort of weird millenarianism
that this this idea that we are imminent
izing the eschaton that we are we are
about to experience the end of time and
this existed in a lot of religious
communities the early Christian
community thought that sort of the the
kingdom of God was at hand it's happened
in the Jewish community too you see it
among certain Muslim sects
well you see it in second with in the
second world to the idea that we are
living in the end times and the
apocalypse is basically upon us and that
means that harsh action is necessary
we need harsh action now we need crazed
action now because if we don't everyone
is gonna die millions will die millions
will die and we keep hearing this about
the increase of hurricanes and tornadoes
even though there's been no actual
increase in the number of hurricanes or
tornados we keep hearing this about
these supposed outsized impact of
hurricanes and tornadoes even though for
example in Bangladesh which just
experienced is pretty significant
hurricane a couple of within the last
year about four thousand people died in
the 1990s there was a similar sized
hurricane a hundred thousand people died
what does that mean it meant that
Bangladesh actually spent the money and
provided the resources necessary so that
fewer people died in other words human
beings as intelligent animals have the
capacity to adapt to our environment
we've been doing it our entire existence
nonetheless the feeling that we are
living in crisis mode has permeated the
left to a really extraordinary extent
and that reaches all the way down to the
lowest level of the Democratic Party I
mean the lowest level meaning the folks
in Antigua so if you haven't seen this I
have to show you this tape from Antigua
in Portland and Tifa has basically taken
over the city for folks who don't know
what an Tifa is an Tifa is a wild
leftist group they call themselves
anti-fascist but they actually want to
do is prevent anyone from saying
anything they disagree with they they
just want to prevent anyone from talking
they wear black they beat people up who
they disagree with they took over an
actual intersection in Portland and the
authorities did nothing about it because
of course this is Portland because I
told you
okay so obviously Antipa has taken over
the city and they're and they're telling
people where to go where the hell are
the cops well the answer is the cops are
nowhere to be found because for months
for months
Portland has been controlled by an tyfa
there's an article from august 2018 by
andy i believe it's pronounced him to go
or but maybe that may be the end in
silent he's an editor qualit and he has
a piece called anarchy breaks out in
portland with the mayor's blessing
here's what he says along the trolley
tracks behind the US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement field office hey
biohazard cleanup crew works under
police protection it finds used needles
and buckets of human waste simmering in
nearly 100 degree heat the smell of
urine and feces fills the block for more
than five weeks as many of 200 people
had occupied the site to demand Isis
immediate abolition they're gone now but
the community is left reeling 38 days of
government sanctioned Anarchy will do
that my mob surrounded Isis office in
Southwest Portland June 19th they
barricaded the exit they blocked the
driveway they send guards to patrol the
doors they trapped workers inside at
night they laid on the street stop
traffic at a critical Junction near a
hospital and police stayed away at this
time I'm denying your request for
additional resources said Portland
Police Bureau Deputy Chief Robert Day
writing - officer - federal officers
pleading for help
hours later the remaining ice workers
were finally evacuated by a small
federal police team the facility shut
down for more than a week some locals
just let auntie 4 run roughshod and
that's not really a surprise the
radicals have taken over large swaths
and left Tom Perez and the head of the
DNC
is now essentially admitting that there
are no moderates left in his own party
when we see that there are no guardrails
in Washington I mean we we know that for
sure there there are no moderate
Democrats basically left I mean the
moderate Republicans left in the United
States there are no moderate Republicans
left in the United States Senate a
Freudian slip there from Tom Perez there
are no moderate Democrats because there
really are not I mean
the number of moderate Democrats has
declined how much so so much so that our
our own producer Sonya is experiencing
great tragedy today I'll explain why
this has an impact on Sonya in just a
second but first let's talk about your
second Amendment right so you're a gun
lover
that means the clock is ticking for you
how would you like to hit the range
tomorrow with a brand new gun I know I
love that and the u.s. ECA wants to make
that dream come true they're here to
help train and protect responsible gun
owners like you and me right now they're
giving away free guns every day so you
gotta check them out they're giving away
a different gun every single day but it
all ends soon just text safe to the
number 8 7 2 2 2 that's 8 7 2 2 to get
entered right now you could get up to 24
chances to win your gun daily it could
be 24 Kimber is 24 Glocks 24 news SIG's
all you have to do is text safe that's
sa Fe 287 2 to 2 and that will reveal
which gun you could be taking home today
but this all ends soon and today's gun
disappears at midnight so you don't want
to miss it don't put it off go check it
out right now text safe to 8 7 2 2 to
get your free entry to win right now
that's safe - 8 7 - 2 - safe - 8 7 - 2 -
just go check it out right now the u.s.
CCA has a lot of great services ranging
from legal services to educational
services they want to make sure that
law-abiding gun owners have all the
resources they need to fulfill their
responsibilities under the Second
Amendment and fulfill the rights under
the Second Amendment go check it out
right now by texting safe to eight seven
two two - okay I want to get to the
saddest story of the day even sadder the
nikki Haley firfer Senya in just one
second but first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire.com and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show live you also get the rest of
Michael Knowles's show live the rest of
Andrew clavin's show live as well also
when you subscribe right now you get
access early to the to the audio and
video versions of another Kingdom season
2 is coming out I believe on Friday
right so season 2 is beginning on Friday
with new episodes and that includes the
really cool visual component you won't
get to see unless you are actually a
member so go check it out for $99 a year
you can get all of those things plus the
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler so
valuable that I once again forgot it in
my hotel room as I am on the road I left
it there for protection it's the only
thing in the safe so go check that out
right now and you can have one even when
I do not also please leave us a review
it
it really does help the rankings over in
iTunes so we encourage you to leave a
five star review if you don't like the
show don't leave a review instead I
would I think you have better things to
do with your time frankly so go check us
out right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
the saddest story of the day there are
no more moderates in the Democratic
Party there is a meme that was going
around among Republicans for quite a
while in which the Democrats have this
tendency folks on the Left have this
tendency where they say things like what
we really need is we need celebrities to
sound off on X Y is Taylor Swift
remaining silence in the face of X
political issue
why Taylor Swift why don't you have a
comment on Brett Kavanaugh Taylor Swift
why don't you have a clock a comment on
climate change Taylor Swift why don't
you have a comment on this local
dogcatchers race in Tennessee it was it
became a meme because the left demands
fealty from its celebrities and then and
then the day came now send you my
producer is a big Taylor Swift fan when
I say she's a big Taylor Swift fan I
mean she punishes me with Taylor Swift
when I refuse to do my recording on time
if I do not record on time she starts to
punish me like it's Gitmo with the music
front of Taylor Swift yeah there it is
right now I just and and it doesn't
matter how many times I tell Sonia that
Taylor Swift is not in fact the world's
most genius lyricist that Taylor Swift
is no colporteur that in fact when she
says we are never ever ever getting back
together together and ever don't rhyme
this morning's and you inform me that
they do rhyme because they both end in
ER it's which Colton quite aptly replied
so does the word murder but it does not
rhyme with you together or ever which is
100% true and also send you should know
that since I have heard there's a rumor
going around the office that Senya is in
fact a serial killer in any case Taylor
Swift has finally broken her silence and
it turns out just like everyone else in
Hollywood and the music industry she is
a person of the left so here is what she
tweeted no she put out an Instagram
quote I'm writing this post about the
upcoming midterm elections on November
6th in which I'll be voting in the state
of Tennessee in the past I've been
reluctant to publicly voice my political
opinions but due to several events in my
life and in the world in the past two
years
I feel very differently about that now I
always have and always will cast my vote
based on which candidate will protect
and fight for the human rights I believe
we all deserve in this country I believe
in the fight for LGBTQ rights because
this is the big defining moral issue in
Hollywood even though we all agree that
people should be treated with respect
and honor in the United States and that
any form of discrimination based on
sexual orientation or gender is well
I believe that systemic racism we still
see in this country towards people of
color is terrifying sickening and
prevalent so this is taylor swift's
basically her her kind of torture note
from the malleus left they they put her
in the room they used some form that
they shoved things under her fingernails
and they asked her to sign a statement
that basically says she agrees with all
of the main talking points at the left
and she did so I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt on behalf of seniya
that she doesn't that she actually is a
normal person who doesn't necessarily
believe everything the left believes but
I have my doubts and yeah I have my
doubts well president Trump has his
doubts as well so Taylor so it finally
came out with the typical left view that
everybody always knew she had and no
one's really that upset about it except
for Sonia the left one wants people on
the right to be upset but I don't
actually care what Taylor Swift has to
say about politics because as I've said
1 million times I don't really care
about what most celebrities have to say
about politics in any case president
Trump I think had the final word on
matter here was president Trump's
opinion of Taylor Swift a sentence no
sentient human being ever thought would
be read into our political lexicon when
George Washington founded the country
I'm sure he was thinking when will we
have a president who was a reality TV
star commenting on a pop stars opinions
of a Tennessee Senate race regarding
LGBTQ rights yep
things are weird here's the presidents
of the United States talking about
Taylor Swift's musical abilities
I'm sure Taylor Swift has nothing or
doesn't know anything about her and
let's say that I like Taylor's music
about 25% less now okay thank you okay
so well done president Trump totally
right on the left has continued to get
more and more extreme in just a second
we're gonna talk about all of that and
we're gonna talk about President Trump's
response to all of that okay so the the
leftist extremism has not mitigated at
all particularly in the aftermath of
Brett Kavanaugh being sworn in so Brett
Kavanaugh is sworn in to the Supreme
Court President Trump
introduced him yesterday at the White
House and left said how dare President
Trump do this oh except that Obama did
it and so did Bill Clinton this is sort
of a regular thing but it was really bad
because Trump did it that's what we've
learned we've learned that normal things
are really bad when President Trump
does it in fact President Trump is an
uncivil boor right that's what we keep
hearing but Hillary Clinton just came
out and said you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for so all the civility
on the right remember we were told that
the right was super dangerous in 2016
and then it turns out the left two
supports anti feh yeah well they're
doing the same thing with regard to
Trump doing normal things in the White
House he introduced Brett Kavanaugh and
did what I think is correct he
apologized to Brett Kavanaugh for what
Brett Kavanaugh just had to go through
for the omen for simple partisan
political reasons here's President Trump
getting it correct on behalf of our
nation I want to apologize to Brett and
the entire Cavanaugh family for the
terrible pain and suffering you have
been forced to endure our country a man
or a woman must always be presumed
innocent unless and until proven guilty
yes a president Trump is correct about
all that stuff it turns out that
independents didn't like how Cavanaugh
was handled by Democrats either by a
twenty eight point margin independents
were not particularly fond of how
Democrats handled all of that but that's
not gonna stop the Democrats from
doubling down here's an MSNBC legal
panelists yesterday talking about how
Brett Kavanaugh is going to issue in and
I kid you not who's going to usher in a
thousand-year Reich just like the Nazis
here it is on MSNBC if this rain that
they now have control over all three
branches of government we're gonna see
if this rain lasts more 30 days or two
years or thousand-year Reich because
that is how that is what these people
have set themselves up for and it's
simply a question of whether or not the
Democrats are gonna join the battle and
meet them at the polls I said it's a
thousand-year Reich now because Brett
Kavanaugh isn't just a gang rapist he's
also Nazi that's exciting news that we
found out about and my favorite part of
this particular segment by the way was
Noah Rothman a guy with whom I'm friends
he's on MSNBC right for commentary
magazine and he started trying to
explain why roe v wade was not settled
wha and he was then accused of
mansplaining on MSNBC because this is
how far we've come as a country he's not
interested in overturning world
we'll make it over there because he has
a centrist philosophy and conservatives
were you heard him Martin he does not
have a middle Servat applause don't do
that you're headed right towards a man
split and you don't don't say I'm trying
to explain something to a woman when it
has to do with reproductive healthcare I
don't ever do that because we are here
is that this is well let's go down the
road of a murderous Nazi regime which
was not just invoked and I'm sorry that
is an inaccurate and incendiary okay
don't use the word explain when you're
talking about reproductive issues but
what if you just got it wrong lady like
what if you're just wrong what if you
don't know what roe v-- wade does or how
it came about or what its legal status
is what if you understand conservative
judicial philosophy its man's planning
now
hey in the words of my colleague Andrew
Clavin I'll be happy to stop man's
planting when you start woman
understanding it's so silly it's so
silly but don't worry the media have
really got their stuff together they're
not they're not out of their minds in
any way so for example when the
President of the United States says that
the left has decided to engage in a form
of mob bakra see Jim Acosta and find you
somebody who loves you like Jim Acosta
loves Jim Acosta Jim Acosta over on CN
and he says well president Trump knows
about mobs he encourages mobs you know
is talk of a mob rule and so on
I mean Brooke have you have you been to
a Trump rally I mean you know you do
hear rhetoric at those rallies that
would conjure up images of a mob go back
to the 2016 campaign when the president
said as a candidate that he would like
to punch protesters in the face and so
on and so perhaps the president knows
what mob rule and and mob tactics look
like because he encourages him himself
okay well so do Democrats because it
turns out that people like Kamala Harris
who is a frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination in 2020
she's now urging Democrats clearly to
use anger to take back power this is
what Democrats are now going to do they
are actually encouraging anger and rage
as a form of political currency let this
last week and in all that we have
experienced in terms of our frustrations
and our anger and our sadness let's use
this week to give us
all that extra energy that we know we
have to remember that the bottom line is
that they may have the power right now
but we need to take it back so anger and
rage these are gonna be the currency
with which Democrats attempts to buy the
next election we'll find out if they are
successful or not in pretty short order
I think I think we'll find out pretty
quickly here okay time for some things I
like in things I hate so things I like
as you all know it's a running joke on
this program that I am a fan of my
friends over at Birch gold vertical is
one of the sponsors of this program I
had the opportunity to sit down with one
of their wealth advisors at Birch gold a
couple of days ago and here's what it
sounded like
but first everybody who watches the show
knows that I'm a big Birch gold fan and
that's not just because they're
advertisers that are the folks that I
trust with precious metals investing
right now Phillip Patrick who's the
senior precious metals specialist is
stop by I want to ask him some questions
about precious metals investing so
Patrick let's begin with this obviously
the national debt is out of control it
continues to grow under Republicans
under President Trump do you think that
the the national debt is going to result
at some point in a certain amount of
quantitative easing inflation it's a
tough question to answer because quite
frankly we don't know how it's going to
end up what I can say and as as you
mentioned of course the situation is
becoming quite dire right our national
debt is close to doubled over the last
10 years now it's been tenable because
or manageable I should say because
interest rates have been very low the
average interest rate on our federal
debt for the last thirty years has been
about five percent we get back to that
level and it creates a big issue debt
repayment 825 billion dollars a year and
at that point it's somewhat
insurmountable do we then revert to
quantitative easing again who knows but
it's certainly a possibility and if the
currency begins inflating obvious it's
one of the reasons that you want to
hedge your bets with some investment in
precious metals what does that mean in
terms of the stock market because right
now the stock market is going great guns
I have a lot of money in the stock
market I'm sure a lot of our listeners
have a lot of money in the stock market
where do you see that going it's tough
to tell right now the numbers are
somewhat frightening you look at
something like the buffett indicator a
key metric for him to do
in value in the markets right now the
buffett indicator is suggesting that the
stock market is significantly overvalued
then you start to scratch beneath the
surface you look at price to earnings
ratios and it really does look
frightening I mean we have a pea ratio
of thirty three and a half in the Dow
then the SP right now historical
averages about 16 it was 30 before the
Great Depression so the numbers don't
look good okay so if that's the case how
worried should we be how soon can we
expect a correction or some sort look
again it's sort of tough to tell because
we mentioned quantitative easing I think
the market in this climate to some
degree reeks of manipulation so how far
can we push these problems away is the
big question I'm sort of of the mind of
the JP Morgan JP Morgan said a couple of
years ago within three years they felt
92 percent Transat corrects that gives
us about a year from today and I'm of
the mind certainly we're looking at
money flows now out of the Dow Jones big
institutions are starting to bail
typically that's a sign that correction
is to follow the big question that a lot
of folks have when they look at precious
metals investing is of course how much
my money should I put in precious metals
because when people hear precious metals
investing they think that folks are
encouraging them to take every dollar
they have put it in gold bars and shove
it in their basement and that obviously
is not a great strategy I'm diversified
meaning I have some of my money in
precious metals what do you think is the
proper way to think about this well
first of all I think you hit the hit the
nail on the head I mean you just
certainly don't take everything you have
and put it into precious metals or
really anything quite frankly look I I
think for an individual thinking about
it the first thing you have to consider
is your own comfort level right comfort
is important I don't think you ever push
beyond that outside of that you've got
to think about what you're trying to
achieve so I would say most of our
customers are looking at a hedge
precious metals work very well because
they tend to be contrarian to the
markets the idea being one side goes
down the other goes up well the only
thing to think about is in order for
that to function it has to be weighted
proportionally and it has to be
sufficient enough to function okay so
tell me a little bit about Birch gold
specifically so I've talked about why I
trust Birch gold the five-star reviews
the the A+
from the Better Business Bureau and all
the rest but folks here you know a lot
of different shows that with a lot of
different gold companies what's the
distinction between Birch gold and some
of those other companies I mean you
mentioned a lot of the stuff there but I
think the key difference for us is the
approach and the style for us it's about
education you know I think that for an
individual to make a decision
effectively they have to have the tools
in order to do that and that's what we
really try and focus on it's providing
information given giving our customers
the information the knowledge they need
to make the right decision for
themselves okay so I have to ask you how
did you get into this business in the
first place did you pretty trustworthy
guys one of the reasons I like working
with you folks at vertical well how did
you get into this me personally I was a
banker I was I was working for Citigroup
I was a wealth manager actually in and
around the time of the 2008 crash I
started to think about what would be
good moving forward what sort of climate
we were heading in and ultimately it led
me to Birch gold group into the United
States well as I've said before Birch
gold group they're the folks that I
trust with precious metals investing
they do have that A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau they do have the
5-star ratings from enormous number of
clients and I know they're giving away a
comprehensive 16 page free kits when you
go and check out birchgold.com /ban so
go check that out right now and get all
the information you need and then talk
to somebody like fill up over there and
he'll tell you everything that you need
to know about investing in precious
metals make sure that you feel secure
because the folks at Birch gold they
don't want to just sell you something
they want you to feel secure in your
investment they want you to know what
your expectations are and as I've said
before we live in a really uncertain
environment politically internationally
things are very good right now well
sometimes that means that it's the calm
before the storm and it's worthwhile
being diversified it's worthwhile making
sure that you have enough in the bank to
ensure that should things change on the
stock market front that you are insured
against possible change in the future
goals has never been worth zero so go
check it out my friends over at
birchgold.com /ban they really do do a
wonderful job Philip thanks so much for
stopping by I really appreciate it
thanks for having me Ben okay a couple
of other things that I like today so
there's a new movie coming out on Friday
it is Gosnell it was worked on by my
friend Andrew Clavin and my other friend
Nick Searcy obviously feeling McAleer
and
and Mullaney are behind it as well and
here's a little bit of the preview you
should go see this because Hollywood
would not make a movie about the most
prolific serial killer in American
history it took a crowdfunding effort by
the right to actually make this happen
stars Dean Cain another person I'm
friendly with and I've seen the movie
the movies quite good and it is all
about the discovery investigation and
prosecution of a an abortion doctor who
was killing babies after they were out
of the womb and was responsible for the
death of women he was operating on
inside his clinic all right listen up we
were looking for anything that looks
like drugs or paraphernalia Philadelphia
Police Department we have a search
warrant but it's a smell
I mean you got to see this this is one I
never met an abortion clinic before
you weren't not gonna believe what I saw
last night how many so far we found
number xxx
how the woman goes into a clinic comes
out dead and there's no police files
been movies like this
you'll be the prosecutor who went after
reproductive rights and you'll be a
racist to boot you've got a lot of folk
would like to see abortion outlaw and
this is not going to be the case that
gives them an excuse prosecution has
offered you a plea bargain doctor guys
now the movies well worth watching and
it's and it's you know the only movie
that's that's ever been made really on
the abortion topic in a serious way so
or at least in a mainstream kind of
crime thriller way but this happens to
be a true story as well my good friends
oh rachel is in this as well so a lot of
friends in this movie so you know take
my review with a grain of salt but then
go see the movie because it is worth
seeing and we should also support
conservative entertainment when it gets
made other things that I like today one
more thing that I like my since you know
it is a sad day with nikki Haley going I
have to do some things I like to to make
myself feel a little bit better about
life so that one of the people who won a
Nobel Prize this week is a guy known as
dr. miracle he's a gynecologist named
dr. Dennis MOOC with Jay and he's been
mentioned as a contender for the Nobel
Peace Prize and this year he was awarded
the prize along with Nadia Murad was a
member of the Azizi minority in northern
Iraq who is taken captive by Isis
members and held as a sex slave for
three months before escaping her captors
dr. mukajee opened a hospital hub handsy
hospital in 1999 and he wanted to
improve the maternal mortality rates in
the eastern capital the capital of
eastern Congo were about 1 in 100 women
died during childbirth but their first
patient hadn't come to deliver a baby
she'd been raped with extreme violence
so the doctor started working on rape
cases he's treated tens of thousands of
women for rape
since the opening Panzi hospital those
survivors who range in age from toddlers
to seniors suffered complex
gynecological injuries inflicted by
members of rebel groups and the
Congolese military the healing process
goes beyond surgery and therapy
according to NPR the pansy healing model
is a 5 pillar process and he talks about
how he's helped all of these women the
five pillars are medical treatment
psychosocial therapy socio-economic
support and training community
reintegration and legal assistance and
he's been known in in humanitarian
circles for years but it's about time
that he won a Nobel Peace Prize because
that actually is something well worth
celebrating thank goodness I mean
sometimes I guess the Nobel Committee
actually gets it right on occasion so
that's that's worth noting ok time for a
couple of things that I hate
so things that I hate today
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez she's back I'm
not meaning a cat collar here I mean I
don't really even know Alexander Acosta
Cortez but you just keep saying silly
things and this week she's decided the
Electoral College is in is the shadow of
slave power this is what she said she
said it is well past time we eliminate
the Electoral College a shadow of
slavery's power on America today that
undermines our nation as a democratic
republic what now so it is worth noting
that the the state of Virginia was one
of most populous states in the Union
when the United States was originally
formulated they weren't necessarily in
love with the idea of an electoral
college specifically because of that
James Madison didn't actually want to
Senate because he felt like we should be
represented by population because he was
from the state of Virginia the electoral
college is not about the shadow of slave
power it's thanks to the Electoral
College that Abraham Lincoln was
president is the truth because Abraham
Lincoln did not win a majority of the
vote in 1860 he won a minority of the
vote if it in popular vote maybe they
have a runoff may there be a different
system but that's not how it worked the
electoral college was designed for a
couple of purposes one to allow states
to weigh in in slightly outsized fashion
and two to provide a bulwark against the
election of complete tyrants it was not
created in order to protect slavery that
was not the purpose of the electoral
college so Alexandra Ocasio Cortez doing
solid work there as for her usual
arrangement other things that I hate
today there's a piece in The Washington
Post all about this podcast and the pod
save america bros it's called the battle
in your earbuds the bros of political
podcasting and their quest to reinvent
pundit ori I think there's a lot about
this piece that's that's good and find
Anzac wrote it and I appreciate Dan
taking the time to write the piece I
will say that I believe Dan is of the
political left I don't think that I'm
making any great revelation when I say
this the reason I say this is because
there's a fair bit of embedded bias in
just even the descriptions in the story
so for example it starts in a drab
office building across from a used-car
lot in the San Fernando Valley the host
of the nation's most popular
conservative podcast was preparing to
interpret reality for his listeners so
we are in you know a drab office
building across from you used car lot
and we both work there
it ain't that drab okay our off
are actually quite nice and then he
starts talking about the positive
america bros and they're just they're
the greatest the positive america bros
they're just awesome
my favorite part of this story is he
asked me about the crooked media guys
and I said and I've invited them on the
show I disagree with everything they say
there's a direct quote but I think
they're good at what they do and Tommy
Vietor who drove a van down by the river
when he was until he worked for Obama
he said his response to me saying these
guys are good at what they do even
though I disagree with them was please
tell babies Steve ban and I say hello
which makes no sense at all considering
that the number one critic of Steve been
in for years was a guy who happens to be
talking to you right now so that's a
bizarre statement but it just shows the
kind of nastiness that folks on the Left
engage in when they feel like engaging
in it but there's so much of this story
that's actually kind of funny so just
again the contrast that they draw I love
this on his show Shapiro reads ads from
a sponsor that sells a three-month
emergency food supply plus seed packets
for when things finally go south pod
save America shows for a company that
delivers fresh ingredients to your
doorstep so that you can cook yourself a
single healthy meal lentils and quinoa
dressed in tahini perhaps as the world
burns notice which sponsor they chose to
highlight for us like listen I'm proud
of all of our sponsors all of our
sponsors are things that folks on our
staff have tried they're things that we
recommend okay so I'm not ashamed of any
of our sponsors but it's just as honest
you suggest that we are selling survival
supplies while pod save America is
selling blue apron because you know who
advertises on our program blue apron
okay so what what what okay and then is
my favorite America through the crooked
lens is a grand experiment ever more
perfect and expansive but endangered by
ancient prejudices persistence in
justices and the despotic dunce in the
White House okay that's their take on on
crooked media right it just wonderful
guys America through the Shapiro lenses
civilizations greatest triumph a beacon
of Liberty and opportunity that is under
assault from an evil self victimizing
cabal of leftist baby killers well not
quite I I do think that leftist ideology
is evil and I think a lot of people have
bought into an ideology that is deeply
destructive to the country but to
present me as some sort of radical
compared to the positive america bros is
insane it's a crazy
crazy characterization they're just you
know they're just trying to fight
bigotry and as for me I'm trying to
fight leftist baby-killers that's that's
my thing because that's certainly how I
talk on a regular basis I you know me
famous for my incendiary rants that's
that's that's my schtick I also like how
they described the office as how the
unde describes the offices here he says
that the office at crooked media has the
look and has the look of a start-up in
the feel of a small-town newsroom it's
just unbelievable how do they describe
our offices I mean this is where you see
the bias right Shapiro's headquarters
has the look of a think tank and the
feel of a refurbished doctor's office
really okay sure and then I like when he
says that we have about 55 employees and
then he's and then we have three other
podcasts all hosted by conservative men
right because we're conservative company
turns out how many conservatives are
working over a pod save America you know
we actually have a guarantee we have a
much more diverse group of people who
work for us then then put the pod save
bros have I would not doubt this
whatsoever
there are folks in our office who I'm
sure voted for a Democrat in the last
election there are folks in our office
who didn't vote at all in the last
election how many non democratic
activists are working with with folks
over at pod save America so you know
it's a overall I think the article is is
not bad I don't want to exaggerate but
I'm just noting kind of the subtle bias
that infuses a huge amount of media
coverage when it comes to this
particular area and noting that that
does have an impact on how people how
people read okay well we will be back
here tomorrow with all the latest
tomorrow we are speaking in Memphis I
believe them at University is a
University of Memphis Memphis I'm trying
I'm trying to remember we are in Memphis
and we're getting the name of the
university so I don't screw this up in
in short order colton frantically
frantically paging University of Memphis
that's right so we'll see you there and
I look forward to that in the meantime
let's take a drink for Nikki hailey be a
little bit sad and we'll be here
tomorrow and no more Taylor Swift no
more Taylor Swift Sonya we're done with
that okay this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018